[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHARITY WORRELL:
Alex Guarnaschelli.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: How are you?
CHARITY WORRELL: Hi.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Is this OK?
CHARITY WORRELL: You
can sit here, yeah.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: OK,
this isn't nerve wracking.
[LAUGH]
I've done this once before.
CHARITY WORRELL: You came five
years ago for your first book.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah.
I was super-cranky.
I'm a Gemini.
[LAUGH]
About half of me was, like,
on the porch drinking beer.
And I came here, and people were
like, hmm, most un-googled talk
this is going to be.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Um, so what made
you ready to decide to
write another cookbook?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Um,
compulsive behavior.
[LAUGH]
No, I'm kidding.
I'm actually not.
I'm an insomniac.
And I am-- thank you.
All right.
Mom, is that you?
I'm an insomniac.
I cook a lot.
I cook a lot at home because
I have an 11-year-old child.
CHARITY WORRELL: Ava,
who's here today.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yes.
She's forced to be here.
She looks so gracious
and hospitable.
But really, it's all a lie.
So I'm an insomniac.
I love to cook.
I cook a lot at home.
And I think that books
for chefs, that are chefy,
where you're tweezing
caviar on tiny,
little pieces of microcelery,
that are then suspended
in mid-air, and they're
from Switzerland--
that stuff is really daunting.
And I find that a lot more of
the cooking that I actually do
is at home.
And so I just apply a chef
sensibility to home cooking.
And so I found there was just
a big body of recipes I had,
that really spoke
to me in that way.
And that's really how
this book came about.
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
Because it's been five
years in between, right?
Because you came
here five years ago.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yes.
A reminder of my unproductivity.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARITY WORRELL: No.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
And I'm teasing.
CHARITY WORRELL: The
book is so full, like--
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah.
CHARITY WORRELL: There's
so much depth in it.
And there's so many-- so many
recipes that are not daunting
for someone who is not a
culinary trained person,
like myself--
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Right.
CHARITY WORRELL: --to tackle.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I just
think how much-- you know,
there's so many cookbooks
in the universe.
I am the daughter of
a cookbook editor.
My mother is basically
the Quincy Jones
of cookbook editing.
And she-- I just said kind of
said, how many more cookbooks
can we put out in the world?
And I went to Martha
Stewart's last book party.
And I said, wow, a book
about flowers, Martha.
What book is this for you?
And she said, it's my 99th book.
CHARITY WORRELL: Wow.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: And I just
said, I'm on like 0.99th book.
So apparently there's
a lot more to say.
CHARITY WORRELL: How did
you choose the recipes?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
That's a good question.
You know, just collections.
Every kitchen I worked in, I
just took notes on a notepad.
And they're all, like, small,
to fit in the back pocket
or in the bra.
So you can write
something down and just--
no, chef, I didn't
write that down.
[LAUGHTER]
And they're just greasy
and butter-stained.
And they have like
raspberry jam on them.
But I just collected
all these recipes.
And I sort of find
that the recipes pop up
in their proper order
as the book unfolds.
So really, I write--
I wrote the book late at night
and early in the morning.
Everybody is sleeping.
And I'm like, oh, yeah.
I'm deep in a
raspberry donut recipe.
And my daughter is
like, what's up?
And I'm like, I can't talk.
The yeast is wrong.
CHARITY WORRELL: I
remember the talk
you did five years ago
because I was here for that.
You mentioned that your
mom did the similar--
was similar in the way
she edited the cookbooks.
You would get up.
And she would still be
editing from the night before.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: So twisted,
my mother, so very twisted.
Yeah.
My mother did the 1997 revision
of "The Joy of Cooking."
So every 10 years or so, "The
Joy of Cooking" is revised.
Why?
Why revise a book like this?
Well, I mean when you have
turtle soup and squirrel
brain in a recipe, in a
book, you don't kind of
realize tastes evolve.
We now have an Instagram of a
double-decker turkey/squirrel
sandwich.
I mean, I'm kidding,
but maybe not.
So my mother was
revising this book.
And it took--
I mean, it took almost
four years of her life.
And I was working at
Restaurant DANIEL at the time.
And I started my
shift at 4 o'clock
in the morning, the lunch shift.
I would start prepping
lunch food at 4:30.
And sometimes not be
set up, by the way.
Just like someone would
order something at noon,
and I'd like, hmm, hope
to have that by the time
they get back from the
bathroom or their phone call.
So my mom and I were
on the same schedule.
I mean, I would get
up and she would
be bent over a stack of papers
at the dining room table.
And I would say,
I'm going to work.
And she would just hold
up a picture and say,
does this look like
a Malpeque oyster?
And I'm like, no, you know,
a Malpeque is a little--
she's like, shut up.
It's a Malpeque.
So she was asking,
but she wasn't.
So I learned, you know.
Does this look like
a Belgian waffle?
I'm like, it's a nice waffle.
She's like, does
it look Belgian?
So things got a little intense.
Sleep deprivation, and lack of
food, and oxygen, and water,
while you're writing
a book about food,
and oxygen, and water
can get a little ironic.
CHARITY WORRELL:
How did you choose
how to break up the chapters?
Like, I saw that--
I was very curious
to ask you this.
Root vegetables and the onion
family got their own chapters.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
You know, I'm
so sick of the non-sexy
veg hanging out
underneath-- in the dark
bins-- in the nosebleeds
of the supermarket.
Like asparagus, and fava beans,
and fresh peas, and pineapple,
right, they're all the ones
that have all this external sex
appeal.
What about the unsung heroes?
What about the kind of
bless-your-heart homely
vegetables that really deliver?
CHARITY WORRELL: You did
a lot of with the potato.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I went at
the bins underneath, rutabaga,
celery root, even mushrooms.
I mean, I feel like
they're always there.
And you're like, oh, whatever.
I'll buy mushrooms.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Unless it's a truffle.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Right.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Unless it's a truffle.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Right.
OK.
But they're not
native to America.
And there are no truffles here.
So I tried also to stick with--
I love the supermarket.
I mean for me, it's
like a wonderland.
I can't-- I go to
the supermarket,
I'm there for two hours.
Just like, oh, look at this.
It's really sick.
I need counseling.
I do.
I need-- like, if I go to a
farm stand and a supermarket,
that's the day for me.
It's over.
So all those mushrooms that--
the supermarket mushrooms
that are always there,
like shiitakes,
criminis, portobellos.
White.
But there's so much stuff.
So again, there's a
supermarket mushroom chapter.
I hate those recipes,
too, that are like,
take three pounds of porcini
mushrooms, fresh from Oregon.
I'm like, I don't have that.
How do you feel about some
shiitakes from a parking lot
in New Jersey?
Will that-- can I sub that in?
So if I'm thinking that,
aren't a lot of people?
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah.
CHARITY WORRELL: We're
not all Eric Ripert.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: No one
actually is Eric Ripert.
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I actually
think he's an imposter himself.
He's just a perfect human being.
It's really upsetting.
Yeah.
He's married.
Let's move on.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARITY WORRELL:
So obviously you
cook from your own cookbook.
What's your go-to-recipes
for the week?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: You know,
I give lots of recommendations.
But as a chef, I approach
a cookbook-- cooking
from a cookbook-- in a
very disorganized fashion.
I think a lot of chefs do this.
I'll take a cookbook.
And I'll look at a pork
chop and apple recipe.
And I will turn it into--
I'll make it multiple times.
And then the recipe will
give me an idea for a pie.
And the pork chop
recipe then morphs
into a great pie filling, that
started with something else.
So for this--
I really liked
the pasta recipes.
And I like them because
you can make them
and when they sit overnight--
after you're done
eating a bunch of it
in the door of the
fridge really late--
I know you're not
here the whole time.
I know you got stuff
in your fridge.
Everybody does it, the
old door of the fridge,
in your underwear
type of eating.
That is so delicious.
Let's be honest.
So I like those types of
recipes for the snack.
And then maybe
the next day, they
taste even better-- anything
tomato based, for example.
Tomatoes love to be cooked and
then left to sit overnight,
or even two days.
I find they're better.
I have a lot of one-pot meals.
Those are great, too.
And people love that.
People aren't going to spend
as much time as I do cooking.
And I assume not obsessively
seeing food everywhere
they look in the universe.
I mean literally, I went
to a store yesterday.
And I was looking at surfboards.
And I'm like, tsk, an
ice cream sandwich,
shaped like a surfboard,
with a flared edge.
I'm all in with--
I'm thinking flavor combos
of cookies and ice cream.
And then I realized
that I just look creepy.
And that some people go to the
store and just see a surfboard.
So probably a lot of those types
of recipes that are make-ahead
or that can sit in the fridge.
Also, there's a whole chapter
of sauces and vinaigrettes.
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
I saw that.
CHARITY WORRELL: So you
can make a bunch of those,
throw in what I call
the door of the fridge.
And then you buy
something, chicken, steak,
whatever you're feeling,
tofu, vegetables.
And you throw one of
those sauces on it.
And then you feel fancy.
And then you tell people you
made the whole meal yourself.
Or just buy something
to go and just
dump one of your homemade
vinaigrettes on it,
and be like, I crushed it.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARITY WORRELL: What chefs have
inspired you over the years?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
I love this question.
So many.
Chefs I envy.
Chefs I want to be,
that I won't be.
Chefs, I'm so mad at
being, that aren't me.
There's a lot of
envy and jealousy.
Are you getting a theme?
And then chefs I just love
to-- some I love to talk,
some I love to watch cook.
I like Anne-Sophie Pic a lot.
She's French.
She's got a three-star Michelin.
And she just stands
there like this, calmly,
with like 700 people
behind her, all like--
and I covet that
kind of relationship.
I go to my own restaurant
to, like, what's up?
What's up?
How you doing?
There's, like, rap
music blasting.
And they throw me, like, a
pint container of ice water.
And I'm like, hmm, almost.
[LAUGHTER]
It's all a matter how you
frame the picture, people.
I like-- chefs I've
worked for or with--
Guy Savoy, who has a restaurant
in Las Vegas and in Paris.
I worked for him for
almost seven years.
And I hear his voice in my head.
I think everyone has a mentor,
or a boss, or a colleague.
And that's the voice.
Or your mother, if you've not
worked it out on the couch.
That's where it stays
for a little while.
I hear his voice in my
head when I'm cooking.
And he just-- the one thing
he always taught me was
do not ever throw flavor away.
If you're cooking
something in a pan,
get the juices from where that
fish, or meat, or whatever
cooked--
and get that into the dish,
and not for the dishwasher.
And so every time
I'm cooking, I always
think how can I keep all
the flavor in the room?
And so that constant reminder.
Because that's true every
time you cook something,
whether it's a slice
of toast, you're
like, collect the crumbs,
collect the good bits.
Everything has-- you know,
don't leave anything behind.
And so he's a big one for me.
CHARITY WORRELL:
So shifting a bit,
how did you end up
on the Food Network?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I know.
I don't know.
I don't-- I don't--
I can't believe it, right.
So crazy.
CHARITY WORRELL:
You're an Iron Chef.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Yeah, I know.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Do you know that?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Oh, I so know that.
Are you crazy town?
I get up every day, I'm like
my life is a complete sham,
but I am an Iron Chef.
CHARITY WORRELL: Well,
what is that feeling?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Oh, my god.
That-- and imagine
it's on television.
I can watch one of the great--
I mean, giving birth to my
child was definitely the best,
but I don't want to
watch that video.
Not my sexiest.
But to watch getting
that title, I can--
my daughter has it
saved in the DVR.
And I'll come home
every once in a while,
and she's like, check this out.
And I'm like, oh,
this old thing.
This old reel of me?
So great, because
a lot of chefs--
I don't know, maybe a lot of
people but a lot of chefs,
I think, are a hybrid
of acute arrogance
and low self-esteem
and no middle.
So we're like a really
great donut with no filling.
And so when you have a moment
that's actual validation
that you can witness,
it mixes that salad up,
and for me, it did.
And so I won, and all I was
thinking was oh, don't cry.
Like, please don't cry, inside.
Like don't get all,
like, you like me.
You really like--
no, none of that.
I just thought.
So I thought that.
So then I thought about
puppies in a meadow,
running in the field, and
flowers and cake, of course.
And then Bobby Flay
came up to me and said,
the best thing about this
is how much you deserve it.
And I just thought,
I can die now.
I mean, we're good.
I went home.
I did this show once
and I didn't win, just
so we're clear.
CHARITY WORRELL: We
won't talk about that.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
No, we will, we will.
We'll talk about
the flawed journey.
And so they called
me, and they said,
you know we want to do
a redemption series.
Will you do it?
And I said, no.
I'm not going to do it again.
I just can't.
I can't have my
heart broken twice.
Many of you have dated people
and broken up and been like,
I'm never talking to them again,
and then the next day, you're
like, what time is dinner?
I was really like on the
breakup trail with this show.
And I called my
mother, and I said,
they want me to do the
next "Iron Chef" again.
And she said, oh, don't do
those competition shows.
You're so bad at them.
CHARITY WORRELL: Oh, nice.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Snapshot, childhood, damaged.
Questions?
I'll take questions on that one.
So I did it, and I-- well,
I said to the Food Network,
can I do it but can you
guarantee that I win?
I think that's fair, guys.
It's like the fair
playing field.
I win.
And they said, no.
So that didn't work.
And I remember just my cell
phone ran out of juice,
and I was on the street.
And there was like a payphone
on the corner where I live.
So I'm half a block
from my apartment
but on the pay phone with my
agent, like, I cant' do this.
So every time I look at that
pay phone, now, I'm like,
pshew you know,
like what a dope.
But I really just thought
if I don't do this again,
if I don't take a
chance on myself again,
I won't forgive myself.
CHARITY WORRELL: Did that
open up a lot of doors
to then be featured more
on the Food Network?
Because every time I
turn the Food Network on,
you're on everything.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
I have people
CHARITY WORRELL: You won
"Guy's Grocery Games,"
you're on "Beat Bobby
Flay," you're on "Chopped."
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I'm
involved with the mafia.
I know, it's so weird.
I turn it on, like,
ah, you again?
It's really hard
to watch yourself.
I like the episodes
of "Chopped."
I enjoy them more when I'm
not on them, watching them.
It's really interesting for me.
Every year, I have a
different favorite judge.
I'm like, look at you this year.
Look at you.
But every year, we go to the
set of "Chopped," and say,
we're here again?
We can't believe it.
And then I fall into a "Chopped"
marathon on my own couch.
So I'll come home from
shooting "Chopped,"
and Eva and I will watch
four episodes of "Chopped."
Net, net, I never want
to see Ted Allen again.
He's like, come over for dinner.
I'm like, no.
I'm so sick of you.
CHARITY WORRELL: When I watched
the "Guy's Grocery Games,"
you won on the
frozen feud, where
you took scallops and
frozen lemon sorbet
and made some fancy dinner.
How did you do that?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
I'm really neurotic.
I love a supermarket, seriously.
CHARITY WORRELL: Sorbet,
I would have never think
to use that in a savory dish.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Well, that's Guy, OK?
That's the Land of Guy, who is
an unbelievable human being,
astoundingly smart.
CHARITY WORRELL: He's on
there as much as you are.
Every time I turn
it on, I'm either
watching "Chopped" or "Diners,
Drive-ins, and Dives."
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Oh, yeah, well, he
says I'm shooting Triple D,
and then I'm going to Triple G.
And I'm like, oh, my god.
You're making your way through
the alphabet with your shows.
That show is so awesome.
I love running
around a supermarket.
It's an incredible set.
It's a supermarket,
fully loaded.
And I'll catch Guy in the
aisle snacking on stuff.
He's like, this
product's really good.
So the next challenge,
they set us free,
and I just take all
the stuff Guy liked.
I'm like, oh, look Guy,
do you like this dish?
I get him to open
cans and jars for me
while he's standing there.
He is really fun to work
with, and I love the show.
So I don't know, something
about the supermarket.
I mean, it's basically
"Chopped" is a great training
ground for any other
competition show for me.
And I'm so unbelievably
competitive.
I mean people are like,
well, I like this sorbet.
And I'm like, why do you
like that one better?
It takes nothing for
me to get rolling.
I mean, I'll fight you
right now for this cookbook.
I'm kidding, sort of.
But I really am
competitive and it's
been such a privilege to
be able to compete on TV
and call that part of what I do.
I started out on "Food Network
Challenge" years and years ago.
I did a Thanksgiving challenge.
We had five hours to make
a Thanksgiving dinner,
and it filmed in Denver,
Colorado and I had never been.
And I really didn't know about
the cooking and altitude thing.
I didn't think that was real.
I'm like, oh, come on.
What's this silly
little mountain stuff?
CHARITY WORRELL: It
makes such a difference.
I learned about
this on "Top Chef."
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Yeah, I mean,
I tried to make mashed
potatoes, and it never happened.
Five hours, I kept believing.
There is like hold on to-- you
know the kitten on the branch,
like, hang in there?
That kind of poster,
I was the poster child
for hoping that the
altitude was not a reality.
So I didn't win, and I thought,
well, if you don't win,
you don't get asked
to be on TV again.
But boy, do they like a loser.
They were like
Guarnaschelli, how are ya'?
I saw you lost in
most glorious fashion.
Are you busy?
Well, I don't know.
I was at home, fielding all
my offers from having just
lost the competition show.
So it snowballed.
I did some-- I judged
some "Iron Chef."
I met Bobby Flay, who I
famously really didn't like.
I used to turn on Food Network
and be like, who's this guy?
Thinks he's so cool with
his grill and his spatula
and his stupid hamburgers.
And I couldn't have been
more wrong about that.
So I did some daytime cooking
stuff, and then I just,
"Chopped" came along.
And I just-- oh, I said no to--
the producer called me
about "Chopped," and I said,
I don't want to be on that show.
Seems like it won't be a hit.
You guys think my career as
a TV exec is just, no, right?
Like no, let it go.
And they just kept calling--
really, I mean I have to say,
there was one Food
Network producer, exec,
who just stalked me and
said, just go once to the set
and do one episode.
And if you don't like it,
you don't have to go back.
So I shot one
episode of "Chopped."
And the floor
producer said, what
do we have to do to get
you to do this show?
And I said, I always have
to sit in the middle.
So I'm the only judge who
always sits in the middle.
CHARITY WORRELL:
You're not kidding.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Center square.
I used to watch the
"Hollywood Squares."
I was like who's in the middle?
Who cares about the suburbs?
Seemed like a good move.
You know what I'm saying, guys?
CHARITY WORRELL:
When you're judging,
is there anything
you've been given
that's been just awful tasting?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Yeah, all the time.
CHARITY WORRELL: Really?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Let me rephrase that.
No, nothing.
There's been a lot
of awful stuff.
And there are a lot of
ingredients that if you
didn't grow up eating them,
you don't have an understanding
of them that's ingrained in
you, you, cannot fake that.
I have ingredients I'm
given where I'm like, nah.
I needed to start with this
ingredient at the age of 10,
either eating it or
cooking it or both
to really understand it.
And that's where culture is
a card to play on "Chopped,"
and if you happen to get an
ingredient in the basket that's
part of your cultural
background or part
of what you ate
growing up, that's
a big advantage, and that's
like a luck thing, in a way.
But yeah, I've had
some hideous stuff.
Oh, my god.
And the worst is when the nicest
person makes the worst dish,
and you're like, I would
love to have drinks with you,
but you're about to meet
that hallway and get chopped,
and that's hard.
Or when someone
is an amazing chef
with an incredible pedigree
and doesn't have the confidence
in that context and blows it.
I can't tell you
how many times we've
had the best cook
out of the four
of them blow it
on the first round
and leave two of
the ingredients off.
And they're like, I know.
It was sitting there.
And you're like, my
whole day was based
on what you were going to do.
What am I supposed to do now?
And I think that's why the
judges on "Chopped" are unique.
I think-- I call us
the cast of "Friends."
I think you pick, like we
all do, with "Friends."
You don't know why.
Like some days you just feel
Chandler-y, some days you
feel Monica-y, Some days
you're singing "Smelly Cat."
I think people do the same
thing with the "Chopped" judges.
Sometimes we feel
debonair, Zakarian.
Sometimes we feel like
nebulous and strange, Santos.
You know it depends
on what you're vibing.
I always say Amanda
Freitag is sort
of the upholder
of cooking truth.
She's like, everything you
did was unbelievably creative,
but your chicken is overcooked.
And I'm like--
I'm much more of a kumbaya,
like, oh, you made a drawing.
How creative.
If I tilt it this
way, I understand it.
Amanda goes right for the
truth of the food, you know?
So it's so
interesting, that mix.
CHARITY WORRELL: How do
they choose, or do you
know how they choose
the ingredients?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
It's a "Chopped" secret.
No, Food Network, we
have a whole staff
of people that
choose the baskets.
You can make suggestions.
You can beg and plead for
things not to be in there.
But it's a group
of people, a group
of trained experts that just
sit around googling things.
So step it up, guys.
CHARITY WORRELL: What is the
best meal that you've ever had?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: What?
CHARITY WORRELL:
Well, I know mine.
That's why I always
ask people this.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: God, that
takes real presence of mind
to know something like that.
The best meal I've ever had?
CHARITY WORRELL: You
never had an experience
where you're just like,
wow, this is like top 10?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah.
I ate in a--
I lived in France for
almost seven years.
Almost all my 20s, I
spent living in France.
And I went down to Nice
randomly for a couple of days
in the Riviera.
And there was a little
hole in the wall--
it's not really a
hole in the wall,
but it's small and
very homey bistro.
They don't have
phones, and they have
just communal tables with
these very uncomfortable
little stools.
And the wife is on the floor,
taking orders and seating
guests, and the husband
is cooking, and that's it.
And so it was literally
like, I grew up
an only child with my
parents, and that's my family.
I mean, a lot of people
have eight million cousins.
And I'm Italian, like you figure
I got a million cousins and all
that.
I'm just, I'm very lean
in the family department.
And it felt like my
mother and my father,
so right away it was a setup
that felt very homey to me.
And then the husband dropped
fresh pasta, boiling hot
and water, the pasta water on
basil pesto in a giant bowl
next to where I was
sitting and just tossed it.
And the steam wafted
over, and I just cried.
And I was like, really?
You're going to cry like
"Like Water for Chocolate,"
like "Eat, Pray, Love."
Like, I had a
personal revelation,
and now I'm amazing.
Not at all.
It just smelled really good, and
I wanted to eat the whole bowl.
And so I ate that pasta
like a complete savage.
I mean, I think utensils were
just kind of on the periphery
of my behavior.
And he made some rabbit
and some other stuff,
and I just kind of cried a lot.
I didn't talk.
I just cried.
And I can't say food,
generally makes me do that.
I mean, on "Chopped," I
cry for different reasons.
So yeah, that might be it.
And I like that, no
phone, no nothing.
You want to go?
You've got to roll up.
It's not on your GPS.
It's just, God, you've
got to really put
some goji berries in
your pouch and climb
a mountain wearing a loin cloth
to find this place, old school.
CHARITY WORRELL: If
any of my team's here,
they know that whenever
I plan off-sites,
I always add an
activity or food tours,
because I am obsessed with them.
I love traveling, and I
feel like that's the best
way to get to know a place.
Have you ever done one?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: A food tour?
CHARITY WORRELL: Yeah.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: No,
CHARITY WORRELL: No?
Are you anti, or
just never done one?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I'm going to
put it to like this, honestly,
it's really hard for me to
have food be any more a part
of my life than it already is.
In fact, the fight
for me is to have
something not food-related.
People say, well, what are
your hobbies that round you
out and give you balance?
Like, how do you find balance?
A, I think that's completely
unrealistic as a goal, first
of all.
Second of all, it's definitely
not happening for me,
and I'm not going to
lie about it anymore.
This is where I come
out with the truth.
I am not a balanced human, and
I don't have a balanced life.
I like my child.
I like food.
I like flowers.
I like boating and
needlepointing.
So my desire, if I
have any free time
is to do something that
doesn't have to do with food
and that's hard.
I'm like, oh, we're going to
a pumpkin farm and an apple
orchard, that's
not food-related.
That's my idea of kind of
getting out of the kitchen
and not thinking about food.
I went to the beach yesterday.
I'm like, I wonder what's--
is that a blue fish?
No matter where I am, I
find something to eat,
creatures to cook.
Not you, yet.
No, I'm kidding.
Do you know what I mean?
So no, but I admire people
that do, and I like you a lot.
CHARITY WORRELL: No.
It's my favorite thing.
I always find I learn the
most, and I learn about these
off-the-beaten-path
kind of places,
and I always usually go the
first day I'm somewhere,
so I had nowhere to go
the rest of the time.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Getting lost wherever I am
and finding those
places, I do that a lot.
I mean, I was in
Cleveland recently,
and I just found Little
Italy and just walked around,
and just wanted to
feel Italian vaguely.
I had like six cannolis.
I figure that's what
Italians are doing.
So yeah, I understand that, yes.
But you mean organized
tours, like here's where
the first potato was cooked?
Just no, no.
CHARITY WORRELL: What, of
everything you've done so far,
what have you enjoyed the most
of your career, the TV shows,
the executive chef
part, the cookbooks?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Honestly, really, I'm
privileged to say I enjoy
almost all of what I do.
I don't like when the
dishwashers are drunk
and they don't show
up at the restaurant.
That, I can do without.
I wish, sometimes, that
I had become a plumber
so that I didn't need to rely
on other people to fix stuff.
That was the math I did when
I graduated from college.
Do I want to be a
plumber or a chef?
And I'm like, kinda,
it's iffy, guys,
because they're actually
the same profession,
just one has onions
and one has a toilet.
So it's maybe
slightly different.
But probably cooking
in the restaurant
is the thing that
speaks most to me.
And I think that's why when
I've been on these TV shows,
it just feels like I'm at
the restaurant cooking.
And so people say, is a
camera daunting to you
or whatever else?
I get so lost in the sauce
that I don't feel the camera.
A lot of times, when
I'm competing, I'll say,
get out of the way
to the camera people.
Because they'll be filming,
and I'll have hot water.
And they're so close to me,
and I'm so in my planet,
I could hurt a camera person.
And so I say, get
out of the way,
and they cut it in to make
it sound like I'm saying,
everyone, out of my way.
So I get all this
mail, like, we just
think you could be
a little bit nicer.
And I'm like, you try this.
So that's been kind of funny
for me, but I get lost.
I got to say, just pure
cooking under pressure
of any kind, that's
my whatever that is.
CHARITY WORRELL: How
often do you still
go into the restaurant?
Because I feel like you have to
be so busy with the cookbook,
especially now you're promoting
it, and with the TV shows
you do.
Where do you have time?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I can go
to the restaurant anywhere
from zero to five times
on any given week.
It depends.
So and I mean, generally,
it varies that wildly.
But I have one restaurant.
Unlike a lot of other
chefs, I only have one,
and I've had it for 17 years.
So it's like a family to me.
To go there and
be in the kitchen
and eating gnocchi mac and
cheese on the line and hide.
That's like one of my--
come on.
I'm at work.
I'm very busy.
So a lot.
And I can take a taxi to it from
where I live, very important.
And I love the people.
They're better people than I am.
It's good to be around people
that are better than you.
CHARITY WORRELL: Well,
that's amazing to have had it
for 17 years, because so many
restaurants come into New York
City and just fail.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I
read the review of Butter
before I worked there
in the "New York Times,"
and I said, this sounds like
a real happening, hip joint.
I want to go there
before it closes.
I read the review, and I thought
there's something charming.
I want to go there.
So a friend of a friend kind
of thing, said go down there.
They're looking for a chef.
So I went there, and there
was like a disco ball
on the ceiling.
And the waiter was like,
hey, what do you want to eat?
And I thought, no.
This has nothing to do
with all the experience I
had had up to that point.
But I went in the kitchen, and I
looked at the chefs, the cooks.
And there was one guy that was
like cooking some scallops,
and he turned around
and he was smiling.
And I thought, he's
cooking the scallops,
and the vibration of the
pan is going up his arm
and making him smile,
because he loves it so much.
This is what I thought I saw.
In the sunlight,
you look stunning.
So I looked at him,
and I saw this smile.
And he turned around,
and that was it.
I was like, all right you look--
this is what's up.
I miss that.
And if it's here, I'm
going to work here.
So I took the job.
We called Butter We Can't
Believe It's Still Open,
for like five years.
Come in every day
like, we're so clever.
But maybe if you laugh
at yourself all the time
and work really hard and just
keep it humble and keep moving,
maybe that works.
That gentleman
cooking the scallops
still works with
me, 17 years later.
He's like my child.
I'm like, where are you going?
You've had two beers.
You're not going anywhere.
He's like, I'm old now.
But you never know.
I really went with it.
Someone's facial expression
dictated my choice,
and I've not been sorry since.
CHARITY WORRELL:
Sometimes you just know.
You have a feeling about
places, especially with work.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Work, yes.
Romantic endeavors
might be a little--
I might be a little less
clever at maneuvering those.
That's another talk.
We'll have Google After Dark.
CHARITY WORRELL: I will open
it up to some questions now.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Does
anybody dare ask a question?
I wouldn't.
CHARITY WORRELL: Anybody?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: All righty.
CHARITY WORRELL: Questions?
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: We're
all staring at your shirt.
AUDIENCE: So you judge people's
food all the time, right?
So is it hard to turn
off that instinct when
you're eating or just
getting a slice or whatever?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
That's a great question.
I grew up with parents--
my mother would
cook from the cookbook she
was editing and ask my father
and me what we thought.
And she collected 30 years
of "Gourmet" magazine,
and she would say
is this pumpkin
pie better than the 1986
version from October
or what do you think?
And I'd be, like, well,
the crust is a little bit--
so I'm going through
this in my head,
that I did this every
night in my childhood
and realized that my mother
trained a "Chopped" judge
by accident.
So I came from that.
I'm cut from that cloth.
And the answer is yes, I
can completely shut off,
and in most instances,
when I'm eating out, I do.
Imagine I go to a restaurant
now, and I take a sip of water,
and everybody stops.
How is it?
I'm like, it's tap water.
You guys crushed it.
So yeah, I can shut off
and really enjoy food.
The downside is no one
invites me over for dinner,
and I have very few friends now.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Big fan.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm watching you
and Ava on your Instagram.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Aww.
AUDIENCE: It's very cute.
So you're on a bunch
of different shows,
a lot of things going
on and we don't really
get to see behind the scenes.
Can you give us any, sneak
behind-the-scenes secrets,
especially for
"Chopped," I guess?
Since it seems like things
happen so quickly, but how can
those people really
come up with something?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Oh, no.
The reason the show is so
good is because it's all real.
And I go there every time, and
I say, what more can happen?
Seriously.
I go there, and I am the
most skeptical of all.
And I went there the
last episode we shot,
somehow someone was
cooking something,
and it caught on fire.
Somehow, something in
the pan was flammable
in an enduring way.
They threw it in
the garbage can.
The garbage can caught on fire.
The set was burning
and I'm like--
the producer just kind of goes
over the judges' table like--
because we kind of marvel at
the humanity that is "Chopped."
And I think now that it's
been on for a few years,
people come and they expect
that even if they don't win,
they're going to
have some experience
and learn about
themselves and grow.
And guess what?
They do.
And I say to people stuff
like, they're saying,
I can't do this.
And I said this is voluntary.
You came here today.
You're going to
win a lot of money.
You don't want it,
that pisses us off.
And people just say,
wow, that's cool.
You know, you need that sit
up straight kind of talk,
that's what "Chopped" can be.
As far as behind
the scenes, I think
I would just say to you
that Scott Conant and I have
a special relationship
with the craft services
table, which is
the table of food
that they put out for the crew.
That's not really
for us, the judges.
But if there's a jar of peanut
butter and a plate of cookies,
Scott and I will go over and to
erase the banana peel fish eye
sandwich we just
ate, He will just
start scooping
the peanut butter.
Like, man, what
were they thinking?
He's healing through half a jar
of peanut butter, and I'm like,
you shouldn't eat all
that peanut butter.
And I'm eating a stack, a
sleeve of cookies, just to heal.
So I sat down with a
nutritionist one day
to figure out, what's a day
on "Chopped" like for me?
And I figured out it's between
5,000 and 6,000 calories.
Yeah.
Well, I'm not going to be
a swimsuit model, for sure.
So I think that's a
really interesting thing.
People ask me how much do the
judges eat or what do you eat?
And often, we do what
I call healing eating.
I will go to something I
have always known to be good,
and I will eat this, and all
will be healed in the land.
And it works, but then you
get elastic waist pants,
so that's the trade-off.
I would say to you, behind
the scenes on "Chopped,"
they open the basket, Ted
says your time starts now,
and they start cooking.
And there's no extra wait, stop,
go, blah, blah, blah, nothing.
And I think that's how you get
these visceral experiences.
They did have a
light blow out once
when they were about
to start cooking.
So it took them about five or
six minutes to change the bulb.
They changed the basket, because
they had had five minutes.
And I think those types
of truths on the show
really make it what it is.
The other thing I want to say
is that, that Bobby Flay, man,
on "Beat Bobby Flay."
People are like, oh, my god.
How does he win all the time?
It's so fake.
Please.
I'm like, how did you win again?
So annoying.
But he really does it.
CHARITY WORRELL: I've
seen him lose, though.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: What?
CHARITY WORRELL:
I've seen him lose.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
He loses, yeah.
I like when he loses
something like tacos.
I'm like, aren't you supposed
to know how to make that?
He's like, shut up.
This is your last episode.
Those are my-- yeah, sure.
It's the eating.
I guess that's
behind the scenes.
Are you laughing at me?
You're so cute.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So to begin, the
cavatappi at Butter
is one of my favorite
things in the world.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
introducing that into my life.
So considering the culinary
world is definitely
a male-dominated industry, as
a prominent woman in the field,
what advice would you have
for young professional women
who are considering
starting their careers?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Is that you?
AUDIENCE: No.
It's my sister, though,
my little sister.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Your sister?
AUDIENCE: My imaginary friend.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
I'm just googling you.
You're an only child.
No.
I get this question a lot.
I mean, I'm going to write
the proper answer in a book,
but until I do
that, I'll say off
the cuff, which
I'll regret later,
probably, I just
always ignored gender.
And I think that in a
gender-fluid time, where
I think we're really
questioning gender roles,
I mean things like referring
to yourself as they,
instead of he or she.
I think I mentally referred
to myself as a "we."
And the we that was all
the little characters
in my personal play that
gave me the confidence
to stand in a kitchen with 27
men and cook all those years
and be bad at it and be
vulnerable and whatever else.
I just ignored it.
I just thought, this is
just part of the schoolyard,
you know?
I find both genders can
be cruel in their own way.
I'm sure you would agree,
but I really ignored that.
I just thought, I
want to be an expert.
I want to be good at it, and
this is what I have to do.
And that stuff was
hard sometimes,
so is learning how to
butcher a side of beef.
It wasn't just the
people that was hard,
it was all the work that I had
to master or try to master.
So ignore it and be as
polite as you possibly can.
Did you ever see this movie,
"Roadhouse," Patrick Swayze?
Probably not.
There's a whole talk in there.
You know, he's a cooler.
He's a bouncer in all
these different places.
I want to hire him to
just fix my life, which
it's a little late for that.
But he says, be nice until
it's time not to be nice,
and he has this whole chitchat.
Some of you have seen the
movie, I'm sure, or I hope.
Thank you.
God bless.
Thank you, Dad.
So something like that.
Keep it inside.
Keep it moving.
Stay polite and try to
be the best in the room,
and then that generally makes
everything else not matter,
even if you don't
end up the best.
People respect you for
effort and hard work.
I don't think anybody can ignore
that, if that makes sense.
And then sometimes all
that just doesn't work,
and it just sucks also.
But ignore.
Hit Delete.
Move on.
Yeah.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I really like
"Chopped" and you as a judge.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering what you
think is the funniest or most
memorable moment on the show?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: No
one's ever asked me that.
No one's ever asks
me what's funny?
I've never been asked that.
What's funny?
Not much.
I mean, the funniest
things to me
are being on an episode
with Geoffrey and Scott
on either side of me.
That is the trifecta,
the three of us.
We have some special bond.
I like watching Geoffrey
and Scott bicker over
who's wearing a nicer suit.
And they'll keep it going.
I mean, we sit there
for 10, 12 hours.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: That's
a lot of thread count talk.
But the two of them, they make
me laugh the most, really.
That would have to be it, yeah.
They're just unbelievable.
He's like, do you see this?
And I'm like I just can't,
with your little thing
and your thing.
Geoffrey is stratospheric.
I mean, you know?
Now, I've got Marcus
Samuelsson as sort
of like a competing
fashion icon.
And I'm like Marcus, I think--
CHARITY WORRELL:
He dresses so well.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
He really does.
I'm like, Marcus, I think
you look a little nicer
than Geoffrey today.
And Geoffrey is
like, exsqueeze me?
He's literally like a
peacock, fanning his feathers.
So I enjoy that.
With all that vanity is so
much humility and intelligence
that it's fun.
But they crack me up
the most, definitely.
AUDIENCE: So since you
don't get invited out
to eat ever, if you ever want to
come over here, me and my wife
will happily have you over.
Just let me know the time.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: I love it.
You will be judged silently.
AUDIENCE: I feel pretty
confident in my skills,
even though I'm an amateur.
I feel--
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
I'll take care of that.
[LAUGHTER]
Buildings crumbling.
AUDIENCE: Out of all of the
dishes that you've ever had--
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Oh, god!
Why are you doing this?
My therapist said
I can ignore you.
AUDIENCE: Do you remember
the best one that you've had
so far?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: On the show?
AUDIENCE: On "Chopped," yeah.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: The best?
AUDIENCE: The best one.
The one that made you really--
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
There's a couple, yeah.
There's a couple.
People usually ask me the worst.
You guys are so sunshiny.
What's the funniest moment?
What's your favorite dish?
People are like,
what's disgusting?
Tell us.
CHARITY WORRELL:
I asked you that.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Get down to it.
Yeah, there was a
dish, I literally
think it's season one.
It was a dessert.
And while I don't remember
everything about it,
the person made a short cake--
like a cream drop
biscuit, and they
had to use pickled ginger
and pickled grape leaves.
The whole basket was like
vinegar or salt bomb.
And they made
basically a shortcake
with all these
savory ingredients,
and it was just perfect.
And I remember I think
I said to the producer,
is it OK if I say
this is perfect,
and that I have no criticism.
And she said, no, but almost.
And that dish, yeah,
that's my favorite one.
I had another one recently
that was pretty good,
but I can't tell you about it.
I've also had some really rough
moments like pureed hot dogs
raw on French toast.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sounds delicious.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah, I'll
be serving it in the lounge
after.
So yeah, thank you.
Great question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious, what
is your favorite New York City
grocery store to get lost
in and spend a lot of time.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
God, these questions--
you guys are so smart.
I wasn't ready for this.
Really?
My favorite?
Hm, I love so many.
I have to be honest,
it's not a grocery store,
but my favorite
place to get lost,
hands down, is the Union
Square Greenmarket.
I start on Park Avenue
and 17th Street,
and I just curve my way-- it's
basically horseshoe-shaped.
And I just curve
my way all around.
That's my favorite
grocery store.
I know it's not brick and
mortar in the classical sense.
But I can eat five apple
cider donuts and 14 muffins.
And people are like, oh, it's
so healthy, the Greenmarket.
Cucumbers and zucchini,
where's the fun in that?
Let me tell you again, I'm a
10,000-calorie moment making
that loop, if you work hard.
And I really like
keeping abreast
of what farmers are making
what in the tri-state area.
I mean, a lot of
it is, obviously,
New York, some New Jersey.
I really like keeping up
on what people are making
and producing, and I buy that.
And we serve so much
of that at Butter.
And I don't have
a wall of farmers
with a picture of a cow, and we
don't have any of that stuff.
We just buy the
stuff and serve it.
Because that's, I feel,
as much as a restaurant is
able to do that
within their means,
to me, that's what a
restaurant should do.
So that's my favorite.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah, sure.
I wish I had an
even better answer.
Dammit.
Yes?
CHARITY WORRELL: These are
the last three questions.
AUDIENCE: So this is like
another favorite question.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah,
God, I'm so stressed out.
AUDIENCE: Who would
you most prefer
to have cook you a meal, of
all of the chefs and cooks
that you've met?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Oh, I'm sweating.
I've got a lot of friends,
but I've got some enemies.
I've got to-- I've got to--
probably, I'm in a
wacky head space.
I'd probably like
Morimoto to cook me
a giant Japanese
feast or Rick Bayless
cook me a huge Mexican feast.
That's kind of where my head is.
You ask me in two
months, and I'll
pick someone French and
someone from South America.
But right now, that
would probably be it.
I really also want
Anne Sophie-Pic,
I mentioned her earlier.
AUDIENCE: You only get
to pick one though.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Stop it.
You're the worst.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
Morimoto works.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
You're chopped.
What?
AUDIENCE: Morimoto
works just fine.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Yeah, Morimoto--
I'm going to go with
Rick Bayless for today.
I'm moody, though.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yeah, yeah.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I love you on "Chopped."
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Thank you.
Only on "Chopped,"
do you notice that?
AUDIENCE: That's the
one I watch the most.
So like I am obsessed
with the Food Network.
It plays in the back of
my house all the time,
and I love eating out,
and I love home cooking.
But basically, I
hate cooking myself,
because it stresses me out.
There's too many things
that can go wrong.
And if I'm trying
to follow a recipe,
it really stresses
me out, because I'm
worried that I'm I don't know,
going to overcook something.
But I would like to be good.
I would like to cook,
despite hating it right now.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Do you want a hug?
AUDIENCE: How can I--
do you have suggestions for
starting out home cooking,
easy things to make
or recipe books?
I mean, I guess,
you're selling a recipe
book, things that
are good to start out
to make it less stressful?
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Oh, honey.
Is there someone in your family
who's a really good cook.
AUDIENCE: My dad's
a really good cook.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Did
he do all the cooking
while you were growing up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: So
the kitchen was like his.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my
mom can't boil an egg.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Right.
I was just getting
the vibe that someone
was very territorial about
the kitchen you grew up in,
and that you then, as a result,
enjoyed all this great eating
but maybe didn't
exactly have the space
to build some
confidence in your own--
AUDIENCE: Well, he
wanted us to cook more,
but I just, I don't know.
It always seemed stressful.
Well, his bar was too high.
It was like, if I cook, it's
not going to be as good as that.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: We
said the same thing.
You just said it
in a different way.
[LAUGHTER]
Very expensive mind
you're talking to.
My therapist is
living in a yacht,
and I am retailing
her third pool.
Your dad's not coming
over to eat your food
unless you invite him.
So there's that to
think about, right?
I would say, start with an egg.
AUDIENCE: I can boil an egg.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
You can boil an egg,
but you can also fry
it, poach it, steam it,
bake it, roast it, scramble.
You can do a lot of
stuff with an egg.
And I think if you take
the one ingredient,
and you just master all the
things you can do with it,
it really, it's a great
confidence builder.
I always say eggs, and they're
really easy to screw up.
They're really easy to
cook, and they're really
easy to screw up.
And so if you can just
fry an egg every day.
Just heal, honey.
Eventually, you'll
say, I'm going
to put these eggs into
a cake and a souffle
and a meatball and a meatloaf.
And then all of a
sudden, you're cooking.
And then you invite your
dad over for dinner,
and you're like, excuse me.
This is my house.
CHARITY WORRELL: And
then the last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I watch "Chopped" all
the time, and sometimes I
wonder if, as judges, you
play good cop/bad cop.
It flows so much, your
comments where, someone
might slam someone, but then
someone else jumps in and says,
what?
This is this.
Are you aware of that,
or do you feel bad ever
if all three of you just--
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: No.
No to all of that.
I know what you mean.
And some days I'm like,
you were so awful today.
And then some days, I'm like,
you're such a cream puff.
But we don't do that on purpose.
And we don't ever say, OK, dude,
you do this, and I'll do that.
OK, you take this,
and I'll take that.
It just flows, and
that's the good fortune
of fantastic accidental
relationships between all
the "Chopped" judges.
And I find like,
I'll say I disagree,
and Geoffrey's like, of
course, you disagree with me.
So he feels like I
always disagree with him,
which I pretty much do.
But no, that's all
organic, that stuff.
Yes, I feel bad sometimes.
I feel angry when someone
doesn't do well that's great
and that doesn't
get portrayed right
when it gets twisted
through the lens of a TV.
Or sometimes I'm very
transparent with somebody,
and people write
me, you're so mean.
I hate you.
[SIGHS]
So when I got my first
hate mail, I called my dad.
I was like, nobody likes me.
I'm clutching a can
of paint thinner.
I'm like, everybody hates me.
And my dad's like, I think
you're starting to really make
it if someone doesn't like you.
That was very helpful.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I'd call
my mom, and she's
like, don't do those shows.
You're really bad at them.
So I've got to a lot--
I have a lot to work out.
But all that's
just organic, and I
think that's why it's so great.
AUDIENCE: So that's
just great chemistry.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Yes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI: Thank you,
CHARITY WORRELL: Thank
you so much for coming.
ALEX GUARNASCHELLI:
Thanks for listening.
CHARITY WORRELL: Really.
And Alex will be signing
books up the stairs there.